for the second day in a row i have a
really good example for you of when an
interviewer
realizes their guest isn't answering the
question
and keeps asking the same question and
it makes the guest look really dumb
when they don't answer the question in
this case we're talking about jared
kushner jared kushner is donald trump's
son-in-law and jared kushner was asked
here
by a k burley from sky news
why did donald trump have those
documents at his house why did donald
trump have those documents at his house
why did trump have the documents at his
house and much like yesterday's example
where former democratic senator al
franken kept asking alice stewart a
republican
strategist when was uh a supreme court
nomination just not even uh uh
acted on because it was the last year
before an election when when when when
when
um jared kushner doesn't answer the
question and so we're going to take a
look at this and of course jared kushner
just wants to talk about his book
and in doing so he says a lot of things
that don't make any sense as is very
common with these folks let's take a
listen to this peace shattered there
very tranquil place for the family a
piece shattered by an fbi rage why did
the president take home toxic top secret
documents
uh you have to ask him uh that question
but you know what i will say is if if
you look at my book you'll see that he
was under constant attack
but he took top secret documents home
potentially risking the security of the
united states yeah i think that it's
something that again this seems like
it's an issue of paperwork that should
have
by the way
that's a new talking point that they've
settled on first it was the documents
were planted
then it was i declassified them then it
was i gave them back when they asked me
but i didn't and there were empty
folders
now it's listen
whatever it is that took place with the
documents
it's a paperwork issue and this is a way
to not have to account for by i mean
they already told the lies so it's a
little late
but the idea of it's a paperwork issue
understand the motivations of that it's
basically saying
no matter what documents there were
no matter where they were
no matter who moved them no matter what
their classification status was it's a
minor issue that's what it means to say
it's a paperwork issue and k burley
doesn't let kushner get away with it
it'll be worked out between doj and him
i don't know what he took or what he
didn't take but i think right now we're
relying on leaks to the media which is
the same thing i've seen the photograph
haven't we where it says top secret
yeah but that could have been fake too
guys that could have been staged yeah
like i said i i i i've seen a lot of
allegations made by the media over my
four years that turned out not to be
true so
i think that this whole thing is
actually elevated so the fact that we've
seen photographs that say top secret
document we should wait and see whether
or not they were even though we're being
told by the fbi
uh that they were
is it the look on kushner's space right
now basically says it all so
the pictures released by the fbi
of top secret documents with the fbi
confirming that they're top secret
documents we need to what exactly who's
going to tell us right if they are not
the authority on what the search warrant
turned up who's going to tell us yeah
like i said i go into my book the
accusations that were made of trump
uh no i just if you could answer that
question yeah i mean first of all he was
the president united states he had the
highest clearance in the world so i
don't know if like this may be a
paperwork issue this may be i i don't
know like i said i haven't been involved
in the details of it he just has no idea
at the end of the day he has no clue and
again he floats paperwork issue and
again understand that every every single
one of these lines
could really be analyzed and looked at
at a deeper level kushner there when he
mentioned it's like they can't go three
words without some kind of liar
distortion when kushner says he was the
president he had the highest level of
clearance in the world
that's not relevant
to the legality of taking boxes of
documents to his house and as we already
know because it's been explored in
detail the classification status of the
documents was also not the issue when it
comes to many of the criminal statutes
which donald trump may have violated so
every little detail here every detail is
a distortion
or a misunderstanding or a lie and what
i like about this strategy al franken
did it yesterday
give me an example of when this was done
to another supreme court justice
well listen i mean it's just it's
precedent but if it's precedent tell me
when was it done and alice stewart
couldn't do it if you don't know the
clip i'm referring to it's on the
youtube channel you can find it from
yesterday um same thing here
why did he have the documents why did he
have the document are you saying they
weren't actually what the picture shows
they were
and they crumble they crumble because
they don't have a defense now
is it believable that kushner simply
hasn't talked to trump about this
despite the fact that we know he's hung
out with trump a bunch of times since
the search warrant was executed it's
really not believable but he would have
been better off focusing on that
from a pr perspective if i were advising
him instead of saying well he has
whatever access he wants because he was
the president or it's a paperwork issue
which minimizes the fact that we're
talking about possible crimes i would
have just stuck to i really can't speak
to this
i just it's it's not about me i can't
speak to this i don't know anything
about i would have just stuck with that
in that alone as many of you know i'm a
busy person i don't always have the
exact correct nutritional plan for my
meals every single day and that's why i
also take a multivitamin and a couple of
supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75
high-quality vitamins and minerals and
my probiotics and it's all from whole
food sources i drink it in the morning i
know i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning when what time of day do i need
to take each one i just get it all with
one scoop you can put it in a smoothie
you can drink it straight it tastes
great and then i'm just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below